Ross do you think it's harder for your
graduating students to enter the
workforce now do you think it's more
competitive or is that just my own
perception being a generation or two
behind I think it's always been
competitive and you know sometimes
people use the word cutthroat there but
I've actually found that once you sort
of get into the the process of working
there once you get a job and so on
people are incredibly helpful if you've
been a good worker if you've done a good
job people are willing to help you find
your next job there or you build
camaraderie amongst the people who do
the same job that you do that then you
build this network of friends and
colleagues and you swap stories over
coffee or beer or whatever when you're
not working but then it also turns into
they get offered a job that they can't
take because they're committed to
something else and they give that person
your name and and so I've actually found
that it even though it's competitive it
there's there's no mistaking it it's
incredibly competitive that in terms of
cutthroat I haven't had too much of that
experience there I've mostly had people
treat me fairly well so going back to
the time when you were those nine years
do you see a lot of parallels between
what your students are going through or
do you mean I realize that's a different
ballgame you know people are shooting
with DSLR cameras and the web content
and all that stuff but do you see it as
pretty much the same it's just a little
bit of a different animal I think it's
somewhat the same but I also think that
that time gives a person a different
perspective on it I had conversation
with my students last year I teach a
course called the business of television
and it's how do the networks work with
the studios and where two agencies come
in and the unions and just all those
sort of the business model questions
about the business but at the end of the
semester I try to give them a sense of
what their career path might be and say
if you wanted to be a writer
here's what a good first job would be
because you're not going to be a writer
right away you may have to be a PA for
the writing staff and then a writers
assistant and then maybe get a shot at
being what's sometimes called the
baby writer on the staff and and so on
and I went through this for different
jobs producer or studio executive and
then said so what you're looking at to
get to this goal that you have to be a
director or to be a head writer on a TV
show or to be a senior executive of
dispute or network it's going to take
you a good 15 to 20 years and I thought
they were gonna throw the furniture at
me I thought the student there were 15
years and so from their perspective that
was an outrageous amount of time but
from my perspective I just looked at
them and said really you think that
having to wait until you're 36 to be in
charge of a television show is an
outrageously long amount of time you
know how much you have to learn to be
able to do that job how much just raw
experience you need to see where things
go right they go wrong how are you gonna
handle that situation so it is about
perspective and I can see it with
students on a smaller scale I had a
student who really wanted to be a studio
executive and she couldn't find the
there's a clear path for that to be an
assistant to a studio executive and she
couldn't find that job for about a year
and a half she had sort of piecemeal
jobs there but then she got a job as the
assistant to the senior television
executive or one of the seniors
television executives at Warner Brothers
television and now she's moved up to the
next job where she's a junior executive
herself now so during that year and a
half when you're a college student or
you're in your early 20s and you haven't
broken through yet it's agonizing it
seems like an interminable amount of
time but when you do break through you
can look back and say it really wasn't
that long it was a year and a half but
you know it's think the advice then for
people who are aspiring is you're gonna
have to be both patient and persistent
that there are a lot of people knocking
on the same door you're knocking on and
so you have to keep at it if they they
don't answer this door try this door
they don't say you know all those
cliches if they don't open the door go
through the window and all of those
things it takes time
you